so let's go back to the game it does
look like Magnus doesn't even want to
allow that position to happen so this is
the current position and he's just
trying to make a new Queen and win that
for the black Rook rather than the
Knight
and uh the question for Liam here is can
he go for the white king if you can't go
for the white king white makes a new
Queen game over seconds one second and
he gives a check this feels wrong now
the white king can start running out
into the open yeah I agree he needed to
step forward with his King For Better or
Worse and uh the king is running the
king is indeed running and this one I
think is just over uh the king doesn't
even need to run out into the open it
can just Shuffle across and attack the
black Rook this is a check now the white
king can just continue moving across if
the black Rook steps across this is a
Check Yes but white will just happily
sacrifice his Queen to make a new one
and we have a result Liam has resigned
wow Magnus takes the lead uh yet again
winning game number eight in a row
incredible what Magnus Carlson